this is Antoine Wiley the
the guy that put it all together what
would be your definition of sodomy any
sex that is in the butt what's your
definition so wow wow
question of the day here which
non-preventable diseases do you think we
could cure or at least treat for a
fraction of what gets spent on AIDS so
let me just set this up there was an
AIDS Walk last weekend and our uh
beloved reporter Johnny comley Journey
for Bernie was going to go down there
and get to the bottom of some of the CDC
stats that you know show over 90 of HIV
cases and young men come from
male-to-male sexual contact or
intravenous drug use statistically
significant unfortunately for us Jean
gee got into a car crash on the way uh
yeah I was pretty serious people can see
this here and um he's okay now so it
kind of screwed this whole super video
for this week luckily for US Quarter
black get was actually still at the
March as the official ladder of crowded
correspondent and here I guess it's just
the experience thank you for for going
uh in zhangi instead and uh here is uh
what he learned at the AIDS March
perhaps the moon knows the secret of the
new sound
foreign
[Music]
the guy that put it all together so I'm
gonna ask you a couple questions what
what do you say whenever people say that
uh there's a stigma on side of me
without a concrete
oh wow you really caught me off guard
uh a stigma on sodomy yeah
[Music]
why is there stigma uh you know not
using a condom when you're performing
um I think it's mainly because of just
the just the thought you don't want to
think
[Music]
it affects people of all walks of life
but like why why is there why is there a
student behind yeah like why is it why
do people not like
primals
I mean everybody has just like a version
like oh
come on man
[Music]
what would be your definition of sodomy
uh any sex that is in the butt
YouTube
[Music]
what's your face
so wow wow
[Music]
my name is
[Music]
crazy
but especially
okay so uh are either of you LGBT if
it's okay
okay
what do you think whenever people say
that their stigma when not using a
condom during sodomy
okay
um
what do you think
when I'm kind of done
[Music]
what about like
if you get poop on the end well Norm a
person that normally has anal sex
doesn't have those problems because they
know what preventative measures to take
uh for cleanliness and those things
yeah what would you do like what is it
preventative measures
um
um I'm just trying to educate you know
like that showering
begin a month
to clean out some use of uh a douche to
clean out so it just depends on the
person and their choices are you LGBT I
am LGBT I don't like to uh I'm the proud
black gay man yes yes one of those
are you amongst the the people
that have AIDS I am I have been living
with HIV for 25 years okay do you you
experience a lot of astigmatism
I like just being out and I I don't I
experienced that but I've been doing
this work for 30 years not just LGBT or
just not gay men uh practice
uh anal sex we know that it is very
common uh among the heterosexual
Community as well and so uh it's just a
People's Choice of their sexual
behaviors heterosexuals heterosexual
will have heterosexuals yes they do I
know a lot of women that love it in the
butt
I know yes
do you have any anything you want to say
to the camera well I just want to say so
there you have it Steven uh section the
butt is still icky back to you
don't wash his hand now
hey there if you like this video
subscribe to the channel or hit the
notification Bell do it I'll wait a
second
do you hear that little ding it actually
didn't make a ding sound I just did it
it happened while my mouth was doing it
and you thought it was coming from your
computer uh so that's fun also there's
some videos playing in these boxes next
to me go watch those you might enjoy
them you might not you don't care